stumbling on the war path that's the
focus of tonight's angle
now over a month ago president biden
assured a very war-weary nation that
putting troops in or around ukraine was
not on the table well now it looks like
that's right up there with the other
promises he made like if you get vacs
you can go back to normal and just 100
days of masking
just hours ago the pentagon put 8 500
troops on high alert for possible
deployment to eastern europe
now anyone paying attention to biden's
presser last week heard the sounds of
the war drums beating
the media desperately wants to get off
the raging crime raging coveted raging
inflation story that's driven biden to
another new low in the polls today
harvard harris has him at a pathetic 39
percent
so ukraine has to be their new shiny
object
tensions with russia over what could be
an imminent invasion of ukraine are
escalating there's a path of diplomacy
and dialogue but there's also a path of
its renewed aggression and massive
consequences that we have been building
now for many weeks
we should be arming the ukrainians like
crazy
we should be preparing for guerrilla
warfare
if the russians go in
guerilla warfare now it's ironic and
laughable that the american press corps
is now coveting about russia because no
group has done more to weaken the u.s
and strengthen vladimir putin let's look
at the record
first
putin doesn't have to spread
anti-american propaganda because our
media does it for him
for the last six years the u.s press has
told the world that americans are evil
racists who are destroying the planet
one in three americans are racist i
think the idea of appealing to white
resentment and white fears
drawing on a particular understanding of
america as fundamentally white in making
this country there is a lot of pain
there was a lot of of killing and murder
and genocide
now the editors of pravda couldn't done
much better and we can't forget the
profoundly damaging and destabilizing
effect of the whole russia hoax which of
course the media spread with glee
donald trump is
a russian operative the 101 contacts
between trump's team and russia-linked
operatives why can't president trump
condemn russian election interference
with the same uh
vociferous russia hacked our election
that was a 9 11 scale event
putin doesn't even need to spend money
crippling washington d.c when our own
press corps does it for free
second the media has helped putin by
supporting policies to increase the
price of oil and gas
now most americans understand that cheap
energy is bad for russia but the media
doesn't want americans to have cheap
energy they've done everything possible
to stop drilling and to smear the
fracking revolution that promised energy
independence
soaring energy prices are helping putin
buy more weapons
third
the media have undermined our military
readiness now for years we suffered
disaster after a disaster in afghanistan
capped by the utter failure to
successfully end that war
now rather than demand changes at the
pentagon pentagon after all that our
media protected defense secretary austin
and general milley chairman of the joint
chiefs
the media wants the pentagon led by
people who believe that being woke is
more important than killing our enemies
for months we've shown you examples of
how hard left ideology is weakening our
military by lowering standards wasting
money and simply protecting incompetent
leaders
of course putin doesn't fear our
military he knows that diversity is no
match for excellence
fourth
the media have helped increase our
dependency on china
last week at the same press conference
where the media complained over and over
about russia a reporter from the wall
street journal urged biden to lift the
tariffs on china
my lord how much more do these people
want at this point
just in the first 11 months of 2021 we
bought almost 457 billion dollars worth
of goods from china but apparently
that's not a lot enough
now for years elites in both parties
have attacked anyone who questions using
tariffs or any other policy to move
supply chains out of china
you mentioned china do you think the
time has come
to begin lifting some of the tariffs on
chinese imports or is there a need for
china to to
make due on some of its commitments in
the phase one agreement
indeed americans should know that a
bipartisan group of senators actually
wants more chinese solar panels to be
sold in the u.s
so both destroying our oil and gas
sector and giving the chinese an edge on
green power that's great
fifth the media have attacked countries
that might have helped us with ukraine
they were and are vehemently opposed
after all to brexit because the media
are slavishly devoted to the eu
in fact our media regularly trashes
anyone in europe from polish leaders to
french nationalists who dare to
criticize the eu
instead what they usually do the press
is stand with germany
which itself is dependent on natural gas
from russia they also want the
nordstream 2 pipeline and they actually
oppose sending weapons to ukraine
in fact sharing german-made weapons with
ukrainians is out of the question
we've been told
the uk is even careful now to avoid
german airspace when it ships weapons to
ukraine itself
so it's easy to see that the more
reliant we are on germany
the more it helps putin
now finally for the last two years our
media has done everything possible to
promote chaos here in the united states
during the summer of 2020 come on they
cheered for the rioters writers who
ended up burning and looting cities
across america
they support da's who don't prosecute
crimes
they downplayed the threat from
inflation that caused real wages to fall
and they protected their hero and mascot
dr anthony fauci
who'd still have us on lockdown if he
could
how is it by the way that a country that
can't send its kids to school
is going to somehow promote freedom
abroad
how can a country that refuses to
enforce its own borders also expect
its citizens to cheer enforcing another
country's border it just doesn't work
that way
the truth is the democratic party's
worldview which has been fully adopted
by the scribblers and talking heads
is fatally flawed
for decades they thought by weakening
america they could promote justice
instead the real winners
from their successes have been putin and
xi
america cannot and must not
dilute the strength she has left on
another hopeless crusade urged on by the
same people who screwed up in
afghanistan
our real threat militarily and
economically is the ccp
which loves it when we squander our
resources and on portland
pointless foreign ventures and quagmires
makes them thrilled
of course the ccp can always count on
the america haters though to downplay
the threat they pose
two days ago the new york times
published what can only be described as
a fawning personal tribute to president
xi
with the games only days away china has
delivered well china no longer needs to
prove its standing on the world stage
instead it wants to proclaim the
sweeping vision of a more prosperous
more confident nation under mr xi the
country's most powerful leader since mao
zedong
wow
but that's nothing compared to the
slobbering praise the ccp gets from our
very own elites
since that onset of the pandemic china
has worked hard to not only contain the
virus but also contributed to closing
the equity gap by supporting other
countries with many different supplies
including great vaccines i look forward
to once again being able to travel to
china to see all of you and this work in
person
it is shameful
now senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell has a lot of war hawks in his
senate caucus including himself
but if he wants to avoid being thrown
out by another populist uprising in 2024
he needs to resist the war machine's
temptation
now this may be wishful thinking
but he ought to make it very clear to
biden that the gop does not support
sending our troops to eastern europe
let all the folks who think we're
fundamentally racist who think our
military is field filled with extremists
let them own this
we have enough failed war baggage in the
gop
and for the rest of us we have to focus
on finding leaders in both parties who
can build this country up
instead of always tearing her down
and that's the angle